la députée aurore bergé et le grand
patron michel edouard leclerc ont visité
le centre leclerc de rambouillet lundi
dernier une visite dans le cadre du
projet de loi climat et résilience dont
la député et rapporteur pour le volet
consommation
l'enjeu c'est comment on arrive à faire
entrer l'écologie dans le quotidien des
français
et comment on fait en sorte pour
concilier les objectifs écologiques avec
aussi des enjeux pragmatique sanitaires
économiques industrielles donc être ici
tout simplement dans un magasin leclerc
c'est savoir si les objectifs qu'on se
fixe
ils sont réalistes un rayon vrac des
publicités supprimer ou encore du miel
et de la viande locale
le centre leclerc de rambouillet fait
office de bon élève
c'était tout l'enjeu de cette visite
notamment pour michel edouard leclerc
prouver que la grande distribution
contribue à l'effort environnemental à
nos professionnels si on veut pas se
faire imposer une loi trop contraignante
et bien d'être force de proposition et
d'aller dans le même sens
je pense qu'on peut pas se contenter de
critiquer d'abord départ de cette loi il
ya une convention citoyenne donc il ya
des citoyens qui ont exprimé leur désir
donc on a beaucoup de propositions à
faire pour développer le bio pour
développer le local pour développer la
qualité sur les produits l'affichage à
l'issue de cette visite une table ronde
était également organisée entre la
parlementaire le patron de leclerc et
les autres acteurs de la consommation
comme lidl et système u en moyen pour
les grandes surfaces de faire entendre
leur voix